Muy bien, tengo esta página web, que estoy
editando, sobre conejos en Khan Academy y he
decidido que quiero editarla dentro de un editor
en línea diferente. Así que voy a seleccionar todo
y copiarlo y luego ir a esta otra pestaña donde
tengo abierto 'w3schools'. Así que he creado un
nuevo archivo y puedo pegar mi html dentro del
archivo. A continuación guardaré ese archivo y
le daré un buen nombre más la extensión html al
final. Presiono guardar y ahora se puede ver que
el resaltado de sintaxis funciona y me muestra
que parece html. Ahora quiero ver cómo se ve,
así que voy a presionar el botón Run,
y tiene esta previsualización en vivo
aquí que abre un mini navegador dentro de mi
editor en el navegador, lo cual es divertido.
Así que aquí lo tenemos, y creo que esto
podría hacer una vista previa en vivo,
así que agrego más signos de admiración.
Oprimo el botón Run... ¡increíble! Entonces,
mientras lo estoy editando se actualiza aquí
y puedo ver de inmediato todos los cambios que
estoy haciendo, solo presionando el botón Run.
Es muy similar al que tenemos en Khan Academy.